6 april is national donate a life month
it's a time to spread awareness about
organ eye and tissue donation mary jane
bellies alive this morning at nevada
donor network with a local mother's
message of donation mary jane good
morning
good morning to you john it's been over
five years since eileen gilbeau donated
her kidney to her daughter haley she
says her daughter is healthy and
thriving and wants to educate the
community on becoming an organ donor as
she knows not everyone is as lucky to
get a match haley dale was just 17 years
old when her kidneys started to fail and
she had to start dialysis luckily she
only had to wait a year for a kidney
transplant as her mom was a match while
the process was lengthy and full of
anticipation eileen says it's rewarding
to see the impact of the donation not
just for the recipient but for the donor
too
i had no energy you know i was
going to high school at the time and
working
and having dialysis you know three four
times a week so it was draining you know
and and very exhausting so just having
that energy back so quickly just shows
how sick i was and what a difference it
made so i think that alone is
is worth it you know to donate seeing
that person just back to being a hundred
percent i would just encourage everybody
to donate um it is it is truly you know
life-changing not just for the recipient
but you know the donor as well i mean i
can't even
imagine
um what she would be suffering you know
had it not been for that for that
donation
eileen says if you want to become a
donor it's important to stay on top of
your health and review all your options
and if you'd like to learn more
information there are a number of
resources available to you here in the
community including this one at the
nevada donor network and we'll be sure
to post a link for you on our website at
eightnewsnow.com reporting live from
sahara in burnham mary jane balleza live
local now